so my fear they were trying to achieve
some people call Hollywood action driver
which is this feeling that you are
pretty much a stunt driver in a
Hollywood movie it's very much inspired
by sixties driving movies like bullet so
it's feeling that you really go to
driving but you're still sitting in a
real car that car has mass it has
inertia it's actually correctly model
it's created by designers that have
degrees in this kind of engineering so
as you're sitting in this car you feel
like this thing has weighed you can use
it to drift around corners to slam into
things and even as you're driving around
the world which has different surfaces
you might be in the Bayou with like wet
dirty might be on gravel you might be on
asphalt all of that actually affects the
car and you can actually feel that seep
into the way you're driving we come in
with this philosophy of all the cars you
should be able to get any and
immediately be able to kind of like get
to grips with them but then there's a
level of mastery as well after five to
ten minutes you're really starting to
get to grip so they can't push the car
to its limits you're really able to go
around the streets of me what I really
quickly power sliding around corners
you're getting that whole Steve McQueen
movie feeling which is what we really
want